in a recent episode of The Lex Freeman
podcast I saw Nicole purroft go ahead
and explain exactly what the trade-offs
of Technology are obviously technology
has been a net positive for the world
it's ushered in the most safe most
economically prosperous time in human
history but at the same time there are
downsides to it and so we always have to
be clear in terms of what the positives
and negatives of any one piece of
technology is here's exactly what Nicole
was talking about we've never stopped
any new technology just because it
introduces risks that's the blockchain
right now like when I was covering all
of these ransomware attacks I thought
okay this is gonna be it for
cryptocurrency you know governments are
gonna put the kibosh down they're gonna
put the hammer down and say enough is
enough like we have to put this Genie
back in the bottle because it's enabled
ransomware I mean after the colonial
pipeline Ransom was seized because if
you remember the FBI was actually able
to go in and Claw some of it back from
Darkseid which was the ransomware group
that hit it and I spoke to these guys at
trm labs and what they said to me was
yeah cryptocurrency has enabled
ransomware but to track down that Ransom
payment would have taken you know if we
were dealing in with fiat currency would
have taken us years to get to that one
bank account or belonging to that one
front company in the Seychelles and now
thanks to the blockchain we can track
the movement of those funds in real time
so it's a it's a curse in some ways and
that it's an enabler but it's also a
blessing I love this clip because what
it basically explains is that even
though there are downsides to technology
there's always a net positive it makes
the world a better place and so yes we
should understand what those downsides
are we should understand how to mitigate
the risks associated with adopting
certain pieces of Technology But
ultimately something like Bitcoin and a
blockchain piece of technology can usher
in way more benefit than all of the
risks that are associated with it the
critics will only focus on the downside
they refuse to see the positives the
potential value that can be created But
ultimately the technologists they're
going to continue to build they're going
to continue to use this technology
they're going to continue to get the
positive impact that the technology has
potential for hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time